يقولون دائمًا أن الإوز مات مدى الحياة
ولكن هذين الاثنين نجا من
المرض والصحة ،
كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يأتي فيها حيوان لزيارة أحد موظفي مرضانا
في مركز الحياة البرية الجديد في إنجلترا
في كيب كود
لاحظ أحد الزوجين البرية  الإوز الذي
يعيش في مكان قريب
يعرج ويسقط ، اكتشفوا
كسرين في قدمه
يتطلبان عملية جراحية ، لكن بينما كانوا يستعدون
لتخدير الأوزة التي أطلقوا عليها اسم أرنولد ،
سمعنا نوعًا من النقر الخافت على
باب العيادة واستدرنا
ونحن جميعًا
جميلون  صُدم عندما رأيت أن رفيقه قد
توغل في
الشرفة وكنت تعرف نوعًا ما
تحاول بشدة الدخول إلى العيادة ،
فلا تقلق من أنه في أيد أمينة تحت
العين الساهرة لزميل أرنولد ،
بدأت الجراحة
في إصلاح الضرر المحتمل بسببه
سلحفاة خاطفة ،
أنا لا أمارسها ، لقد وقفت هناك طوال
الوقت ويمكنها بالفعل مشاهدة
الإجراء
الذي كان يسحق مثل الصقر أو
مثل الإوزة ، أعتقد
بعد 45 دقيقة من بدء الجراحة
انتقلوا إلى أرنولد أمام
الأبواب مباشرة وأعطوه
الأكسجين وعندما استيقظ أرنولد تمامًا
بدأ رفيقه في إعداده ، اضطروا إلى
بتر رقم
ولكن أرنولد يجب أن يكون قادرًا على العيش بشكل
طبيعي في غضون أسابيع قليلة في
غضون ذلك يأتي رفيقه ويذهب باستخدام
حديقة العيادة
ككافيتيريا بالمستشفى وحتى اختيار وجبات أرنولد
لا يحب الطريق الكبير أحد المعلقين
وعاشوا في سعادة دائمة بعد أن
نشروا حديثًا آخر عن قصة حب
يستحق هذا الشخص الحديث عنها